papers on a variety of topics which
makes it even more interesting so
um without further ado i will let the
speakers um to start their talk
um
please feel free to
write your question in the chat and i
will monitor the chat
um
frequently in um
yeah so uh we will start with all that
testing distributions of
huge objects so although please share
your spines
oh thanks
little sickle change
okay so i'm
you hear me eh yeah
can you hear me yeah
oh or not yeah okay thanks
uh so dana was supposed to give the talk
but
somehow we felt that it is more fun if i
give it although it's not clear why uh
so let's try uh so the talk is about
testing distribution of huge objects and
this title is supposed to reflect that
it is a
this model that we are going to
introduce and to initiate study of uh is
a hybrid of two standard models which
are described next
uh
the slides have done a slides so i don't
know my name my way well in them but
we'll try our best so the first model is
a a
standard model of testing properties of
strings or functions
the objects here are strings of
functions
and
a property is just a set of strings
and the algorithm has a query access
to
a to the string and
so that actually i should have started
saying something else
when you talk about a property testing
it's a type of subliminal
time algorithm and
you have to specify actually because
it's sublinear you have to specify two
things and the first thing is how are
you going to access the objects that you
are testing and the second thing is what
is the distance measure because we'll
have a notion of confirmation because we
don't have in sublinear time or in
sublinear complexity we don't have time
to read the entire object so we cannot
make a an exact verdict about it so we
can only make an approximate verdict an
approximate verdict requires a measure
of a and the measure will be how close
is the object to the property
uh so if we go to the standard
distribution
to the standard the testing model of
testing strings that i started to
describe
the way you access an object which is a
string is by query
query in its bits
and the
distance measure which you say what is
the distance of a object to the property
is just the relative
distance between the object and the
closest object
that has the property so this is a
standard the testing property model
there is also a standard the
distribution testing model
which is vastly different here here the
objects are
actually
distributions and the property is a set
of distributions
and the access is that you get samples
from the distribution
and they
you are obtaining a small number of
samples and
the question is then what do you verdict
you make and what is a distance measure
and the distance in this case is a total
variation distance between distributions
so this is the standard thing
and
what i wanted to stress is that
the complexity is sublinear
so in the case of testing strings it
means that
it's smaller than the length of the
string in the case of testing
distributions uh the domain from which
the element is coming is large and the
complexity you want it to be smaller
than that or compared to that anyhow
that's the
thing that you have in mind
and they
in all cases it's randomized algorithm
so there is a probability of errors that
i'm going to ignore uh
so as i said the new model is a hybrid
of both models it's a model of testing
this properties of distributions but the
distributions have to be thought of as
big strings so it's very long strings
and therefore you are not able to read
all of them
so a as as usual i have to specify two
things first is my my access way
my way of accessing the object which is
in this case a distribution on huge
objects uh and the
so the way i'm going to access the the
the distribution is that i get samples
from the distribution
but i'm not reading the entire sample
i'm just allowing a query access into
the samples that i i got
so this is a non-standard thing so you
see the hybrid of
both models the first that you are
getting samples and the second that you
don't read the entire things that you
get but rather you only a query inside
it
uh
so
the picture is supposed to show it
the second thing is that what is your
distance measure now and the distance
measure i want it to be more refined
than the total variation distance
because it has to reflect this notion
that i'm not accessing the entire a a
string so the thing that is natural here
is to say that if you move if you move
some probability mass from one string to
another string you don't
pay a unit cost like you would in the
total variation distance but rather you
pay a cost which is proportional
to
a relative heming distance between the
two strings so this is really the earth
mover distance
under the normalized hamming distance so
this is really what the distance we are
talking about and there is a formal
definition here and i don't want to go
into it i just want to show that it is
vastly different from total variation
distance consider the following two
distribution one is uniform over strings
that start with zero and the other is
uniform of a strings that start with one
in total variation distance they are at
distance one at maximum distance because
we're talking about distribution on this
joint
supports but in the earth mover distance
they are in very small distance because
it's enough really to change one bit in
order to move the mass from these guys
to these guys
okay a
sourcing
and there is a name so in order not to
say all the time distribution of a huge
object and that's the name of our model
we call it say
model and
but i'll forget to pop up to pronounce
it
okay so uh just some initial
observations uh
the first one is that really uh this
model is a generalize it's not
surprising since that's a hybrid of the
two standards models you can really
naturally or unnaturally a a
a
embed or present or think of the origin
of the standard models special cases of
this model and i'll not get into details
if you think about it for two minutes
you can see it
the second observation is that if you
compare this model to the standard model
then the sample complexity of testing a
property in this model may be smaller
than the sample complexity of testing
the same property in the standard model
and the reason is the distances here are
smaller since distances here are smaller
you have to reject only things which are
far from the a
maybe i didn't even define what property
testing is
so usually we want to distinguish
elements which have the property from
elements which are absolute far for the
property where epsilon is a proximity
parameter
so the issue is
it's a promise problem so the question
is for what a object do we have to give
the right answer so if an object is a a
close
according to one measure but far
according to the other measure so when
we act well but with the other measure
we have to reject but when we
work with the first measure we may not
need to reject because because it's
smaller than the proximity parameter
okay so the third observation is really
a triviality is that
what we really want to study is not so
much the sample complexity
in the door model which was the subject
of the previous observation but rather
the query complexity in this model and
there is an obvious answer that the
query complexity in this model is just
the sample complexity in this model
times the length of the strings but of
course we are not interested in this
idiotic case
so what we are interested is in the case
that a the query complexity is much
smaller or significantly smaller if you
want then this project then see then and
this product then this obvious bound and
this is really the focus of this work to
initiate a study of which properties can
be tested in such a
complexity a
so
we have one result we have several
results but we have a one result in this
direction and the result in this
direction is really a win in a way it
says that we can do it in for some type
of properties so i want to describe what
type of properties we can do it for so
the type of properties that we can do it
for our properties of distributions that
are closed under mapping
what about the time i'm i'm done oh oh i
should stop
okay so i'll just say sorry i'm totally
off
so so
basically i'll just state the theorem
the theorem says that a
if you consider a properties that are
closed under mappings which means if
something has a property and you take
some mapping
from the strings into other strings then
you get a new distribution on strings
and this distribution has to have the
property also so if the property has
this feature and properties which have
this feature can contain for example
properties that have bounded support
size or uniformity of over some set then
a a you have the feature that the query
complexity is really just the sample
complexity in the standard model times
some things it doesn't depend on the
length of the string so i'm sorry for
going over time here i didn't notice
um yeah dana is helping a but
the head came too loud
too late so i'm not thanking you i'm
asking for forgiveness
i know no worries uh it's all right
so i have one quick quick question so in
and the model that you described um
so okay so the query complexity is
basically the sum of the queries that
we make to the samples but for the same
sum
we might actually be able to have
different um you know trade-off between
the number of samples we take and the
number of queries we do
per sample
right
does your
is there any preference for the
basically what i'm trying to ask is that
if if the total number of queries are
the same
um
how do we measure like do we have a
special preferences for the arguments
that take the lowest number
naturally i would say that if only is
equal then we prefer less samples so the
sample complexity is definitely a
measure that we consider uh but the
primary measure for us is query
complexity of course somebody come can
come
and they think differently but what
you're proposing is it could be even a
trade-off you know i'm using slightly
more uh queries but i use uh i'm using
vastly less samples and should i prefer
it or not i think it depends on the
application and let's say
the existence of such things i don't
know if an example of such a
thing but the existence of such thing is
also a natural open problem
in my opinion
okay um
uh there is
one more
[Music]
um
question on the chat about um
could you elaborate a bit about the
choice of earth mover distance why is
that the natural metric
uh
it's it it it is hard to answer such
questions so basically a i think that
the moment you say that uh you restrict
your query complexity it's just a as a
standard property testing then you have
to give some relaxation
it sounds as a natural relaxation to me
but
one could they argue that a one one can
put a different a
like a people have a study
for example edit distance a in the
standard model you can also start a
composer a smoother distance with the
else
with with the edit distance in this
model and there would be a different
model but i think that really you want
you don't want to measure it by by just
by say
total variation distance because this
will require force you to read the
entire sample
okay thank you
um so we will um
move to the um
next talk
and um
it's by hey zhu
and um please share your slides
uh hello can you say the screen yes
okay also hello everyone i'm hi guys
you're from team university today i'm
going to introduce our work embeddings
and labeling schemes for estar
this is a joint work with talia eden and
the future indeed from mit
estar is a classical and popular
algorithm for pathfinding and has been
used in many fields like robotics and
game solving since 1960s
although a star has good empirical
performance there are few studies on its
running time analysis
install search uses a heuristic function
to estimate the distance from one vertex
to the destination
the quality of this heuristic function
directly determines the performance of a
star
traditionally the heuristics are chosen
by human experts based on the properties
of the underlying problem
recently there is a trend to use machine
learning to automatically learn the
heuristics
our paper want to start is the potential
of these learning heuristics we try to
understand the relationships between the
heuristic function and asl's running
time
first before starting our analysis we
need to formalize the procedure of a
star algorithm and some properties of a
star please see the pseudocode on this
page
a star starts with a set capital s
equals s which is the the south vertex s
at each time a star expands a vertex u
according to the
this rule it will select the uh the
vertex with the minimum estimated
distance uh calculated by the d u plus h
u t uh here d u is the distance from uh
s to u and aut is the estimated distance
from u to the destination t and this is
provided by decrease function x
and then this new vertex u will be added
to the set capital s and use this to do
the iteration and update the distance to
other vertices
in this loop
this process this this while loop
process will end when the definition t
is added to the cell capital s
so here is a toy example for a style
algorithm
uh in this graph we want to query the
distance from a to f and uh the black
numbers here on the edge are edge waves
and the the blue numbers above each
vertex as the estimated distance lower
bound from itself to the destination
provided by our this function h
and initially x1 0 the capital s equals
to a which is only the starting point
and the in round one the next qb scan is
a b because one plus one equals two
which is the smallest among all the
other vertices
and the next to b scan is c uh by
according to the rule on the last page
and then e will be scanned and finally f
will be scanned by a star
in this page we will briefly introduce
two propositions for the for our later
analysis they are consistent heuristics
and scan condition
according to heart sr 1968 consistent
heuristics guarantee that when a start
stop condition is meet which is when the
definition is added to the set capital s
the shortest path must have already been
found but thus ensuring it starts
correctness to find the exactly the
shortest path
and in our paper we will only consider
the performance for those consistent
heuristics
if asia use consistent heuristics and
then we have another
we have the scan condition also provided
by heart at all it says that one vertex
you uh whenever you here will be scanned
by a star or in other word will be added
to the cell capital s before t is added
to the set if the distance from s to u d
f u plus f u t is smaller than the the
distance from s to t
well this is an inequality but when this
inequality becomes an equality uh
whether you will be scanned is a little
bit tricky and will depend on the time
breaking rule we will mix the tie break
here for simplicity so
you can refer to our paper to see how it
cooperates the tie breaking here
the metric in our paper we consider are
called additive
c on average uh let's see our definition
1.1
before giving the formula we will give
two notations first
the first notation is p s t which
denotes the vertices on the shortest
path between the starting point and the
destination
and capital s h as t is the vertical
scan by our h-star given
given the starting point the ending
point and the relative function h
and this is a torx sample on the last
page and in this graph a pas equals aces
which is the chartered path between a2s
and the the second set has an additional
vertex b because b is scanned by a star
but not on the shortest path
we see that heuristic h has additive
overhead cr average it's for randomly
chosen pair of vertices
a star scans at most c additional
vertices than the minimum possible
number of vertices
note that our metric only takes into
account the size of this set as of not
not the time spent by the whole
algorithm and it has been seen as a
property of the heritage function and
the graph
the main heuristic types we consider for
our paper and estar are non-heuristic
and liberal holistic we think that their
generality can cover most of the
commonly used corrective function
we first say definition 1.3
uh phenomenal heuristics this is its
expression we first designed a mapping
pipe projecting each vertex to a vector
in a high dimensional space of a
dimension d
and then we use the lp norm in the
embedded space to calculate the
estimated distance between two
vertex and then in that page 1.4 is our
our called labeling heuristics
for labeling heuristics first we also
divide design a function f projecting
each vertex to
a high dimensional vector with less air
and then we use a mapping g like a pair
of
vectors to a length estimate distance
lower bound
the difference here is that compared
with normal heuristics labeling
heuristics
supports arbitrarily
the function g but not need to be the lp
norm
uh however we require that the the value
in each dimension must be a value taken
from 0 to c so it has a limited
precision
and for non-heuristics which does not
have these requirements for for the
high dimensional vector
uh this is our table result and in the
remaining of our presentation i will
elaborate on this table
uh so there are many results and we
first look at this one when we first
look at field 126 the the lower bound
result for lp normal heuristic
our theorem says that we can construct a
invertex graph
if the embedded space embedded dimension
d is smaller than n over log n
in here then a star will scan omega n
number of vertices we can contrast it to
a hard instance to let a star suffer
from this high complexity also
a qrp norm who raises covers the
commonly you common use
manhattan norm and euclidean node and
this result says that in in our uh
instance a star's performance is no
better than the trivial data extract
our next uh we next we will talk about
zero one two seven on the lower bound
four l infinity normal heuristics
our result says that we can construct a
weighted and vertex graph whose maximum
charges pass consists of constant number
of hops such as if a star heuristics use
an infinity norm in an embedded space of
dimension d smaller than n to the power
of alpha then install will scans at
least n to the power of one minus alpha
vertices on average
here r5 is an arbitrary parameter to be
set between zero and one
additionally our constructed instance
for this lower bound theorem can be
transformed into a grid graph if alpha
is smaller than 0.5 and this is the
result for 0.3.4 here
next we'll talk about 71.8 the lower
bound result for labeling heuristics
the result for labeling heuristics
achieves almost the same trade-off here
n to the power of alpha versus n to the
power of one minus r compiler with the
previous one so we can give the
statement here
although they have the
almost the same trade-off but they use
different approved strategy
one more minute
uh then we talk about our upper bound
results we will only present the
stronger version zero and one point
twelve zero one point twelve says that
uh assume the unique assuming unique
negatives of charges pass path
we can construct a consistent labeling
heuristic of length n to the power of
alpha enjoying an average overhead n to
the power of one minus alpha so this is
a matching upper bound and upper bound
compared with the previous theorem
so this is our table
in conclusion we theoretically studied
the performance of a star algorithm by
analyzing the relationship between the
complexity observative function and the
number of vertices scanned
for non-heuristics and labeling to risk
covering the most commonly used type of
heuristics we provide a matching lower
bound and upper bound results and our
results can also be potentially used in
the real case because they can be
transformed into great graphs and that's
all thank you
thank you very much um
okay so um also random applause um which
we don't get that much in the zoom
conferences
um
okay so any questions
so um
i think our next speaker is item
yes i'll show this guy
so i will uh i will um
i will let you know when you have one
one minute left okay thank you okay
thank you so can you see my screen in
like full
yes
okay great so hi everyone i'm edan and
today i'll talk about our work on
sublinear time computation in the
presence of online erasers this is joint
work with sofia at boston university and
it's in verma chennai mathematical
institute
in this work we initiate the study of
sublinear time algorithms that compute
in the presence of an online adversary
a sublinear time algorithm is a
randomized algorithm that has query
access to some very large data set via
an oracle we represent the data set via
function f
and the algorithm is supposed to output
some approximate answer about the
function after making a subliminal
number of queries in the size of the
input function
the adversarial model we consider is the
following after answering each query to
the data set the oracle or the adversary
can hide a small number of entries
sorry this is something in the chat
okay
so the adversary model which we call the
online erasers model is parameterized by
a natural number t
after answering each query of the
algorithm the oracle can erase up to t
entries from the input function
i'll demonstrate this model for the case
when t is equal to one
at the beginning of the runtime of the
algorithm all the entries of the
function are non-erased
suppose the algorithm's first query is
entry two
then the oracle first has to answer this
query by returning f of 2.
then the oracle can erase one entry from
the function suppose it chooses to raise
entry 3.
then the value of 3 will be hidden by
from the algorithm for the remainder of
its running time if the algorithm at
some point queries entry 3 then it will
receive a special erasure symbol
and this process is repeated for
every query of the algorithm
there are some motivating scenarios that
we consider for this model the first
scenario considers the case of
individuals who request that their data
be removed from a data set
particular such requests can be adapted
to the queries of the algorithm as
individuals can be prompted to restrict
access to their data after noticing an
inquiry into their or others data
another scenario is that of a legal
setting when an organization is served a
subpoena the organization is legally
bound to first answer this query but
afterwards they can destroy related
evidence that was not involved in the
subpoena
the tasks we consider in this model are
in this work our standard property
testing tasks which are
which is a subset of sublinear time
algorithms property testing was first
introduced by rubio felt sudan and
goldberg alvarez
in this case the sublinear algorithm is
parameterized is given a
value epsilon between zero and one
and its goal is to accept if the
function f has some specified property
and reject with high probability of the
function is
far from the property where the distance
is measured by this parameter epsilon
and by epsilon far we mean that the
function must be modified in at least
epsilon fraction of its domain to have
the property
and we also want the tester to make a
sublinear number of queries in the size
of the input function
we consider property testing in the case
where access to the function is via the
adversarial oracle that i just described
then the goal of an epsilon online
erasure resilient tester is the same as
that of a standard tester it's supposed
to accept the function as the property
and reject with high probability if a
function is epsilon part from the
property
show the following results some
properties of function can be tested in
the
in our model with the same query
complexity as in the standard model
namely these properties are linearity
and quadraticity and here we're
comparing query complexity for a
constant erasure budget t
then for linearity we show matching
upper and lower bounds in terms of the
erasure budget t
on the other hand we show that some
properties are impossible to test in our
model even for t equals to one one such
property is sortiness of arrays
and the key takeaway from this result is
that the structural violations to the
property play an important role in
determining the stability of the
property within our model
so in the rest of the talk i'll just
give some high level overview of our
results on linearity testing
we consider functions which are boolean
valued and whose domain is the
dimensional hypercube
such a function is linear if it can be
expressed as a sum of
input bits for some subset of the bits
equivalency can be shown that such a
function is linear if f of x plus f of y
is equal to f of x plus y for all points
x and y in the domain
linearity testing has been the standard
model has been widely studied due to its
connections with probabilistically
checkable proofs and hardness of
approximation results
in the standard model it can be tested
with one of our epsilon queries the
tester was introduced by blam ruby and
rubycode and then the analysis was
tightened by belar coppersmith hashtag
kiwi and sudan
in our model of online erasers we showed
that linearity can be done with log t
over epsilon queries recall that t is
the erasure budget that is given to the
adversary
and we also show a lower bound of log t
for the query complexity
the tester of blam ruby and rubenfeld is
very simple it repeats the following
procedure it samples two points x and y
uniformly at random from the domain then
it queries the values f of x f of y and
f of x plus y and it rejects if f of x
plus f of y does not equal f of x plus y
since this cannot happen for a linear
function
in this case we say that the pair xy
violates linearity
then the analysis of the tester depends
on this key structural theorem of belar
el which says that if a function is
epsilon far from linear then an epsilon
fraction of the pairs x and y in the
domain will violate linearity
it's not too hard to see that the
online erasers will break the blr tester
if the algorithm queries to point x and
y
and it might receive their values f of x
and f of y but afterwards the oracle
will erase the value
of f at x plus y and so if the function
is far from linear then the tester would
never be able to see a violation to
linearity
so we need to consider a new linearity
tester
and to analyze this tester we also come
up with a new structural theorem which
generalizes the previous theorem of
bellaretan
this theorem says that if a function is
epsilon far from linear then for all
even k an epsilon fraction of the k
tuples x1 x2 up through xk violate
linearity
by which we mean that the sum of the
values f of x1 plus f of x2 up to f of
xk does not equal the value of f at the
sum x1 plus x2 up to xk
and the proof is also via for real
analysis and it generalizes
the proof of delar at all
in the next slide i'll give you like a
high level description of the algorithm
and you'll see how the structural
theorem plays
uh like plays an important role in this
algorithm
so the algorithm is as follows if first
score is a reserve of log t over epsilon
points that are sample
iid from the domain
i recall the t is reached for query so
suppose it queries this like four points
to begin with
then the
adversary can erase linear combinations
of these points so the edges here
represent sums of points
then the tester repeats the following
one over epsilon times
it samples an even number of points from
the reserve
and it queries their sum so if the
tester is lucky in this case it will
query either like the sum of x1 x4 or
the sum of all four points which has not
been erased by the oracle
then the tester checks if the sample and
this and it sound violates linearity and
rejects if the tuple is violated
and if it finds no violation after
repeating this checks it will then
accept
okay so that describes our
results on linearity testing so i'll
conclude with
some open questions
so as i said in this model we can test
whether a function is a polynomial of
degree at must one and a polynomial of
degree m is two which is linearity and
quadraticity but is it possible to test
in our model whether a function is a
polynomial of degree m escape or any k
greater than 2.
the standard model this is possible with
very efficiently with 2 to the k over
epsilon queries by a result of alone era
the next question concerns the query
complexity for testing quadraticity
so the
for linearity will show both matching
upper lower bounds in terms of the
dependency on t
for quadraticity we have a tester which
is efficient in terms of the dependence
on the distance parameter epsilon but
the dependence on t is doubly
exponential
so the question is what is the right uh
what is the query complexity in terms of
t
another question is about the comparison
between our model and another erasure
model introduced by dick sharashonikova
takurta embarma
in which the erasers to the function are
done before the algorithm makes any of
its queries and for this reason we refer
to that model as the model of offline
erasers
the two models are not directly
comparable because eurasia's are
budgeted differently
we show that sortiness is impossible to
test in our model but it's very
easily testable in the model of offline
erasures
the question is whether there's a
property for which the inverse holds it
has smaller query complexity in the
online model than in the outline model
finally it'd be interesting to study
other sub linear tasks in this model so
we only study property testing tasks but
the model of online erasers is defined
more generally to work for any sublinear
task
such
such examples of interesting tasks would
be estimating parameters of graphs or
functions
so this is for that's it for our talk
thank you
i hear the alarm
um precisely finished
um
so um
i am not sure who is going to speak for
the next paper
um
but um let us know in the chat if you
don't have the panel list privileges
or
if you have just share your slides
should i stop the share
yeah thank you
oh by the way you have time for a
question from aiden um if you have
questions
um
so um what's our empirical example of
the application real model
so one example we consider is for
example if you're running an algorithm
but individuals request that their data
be removed from the data set at some
point
um
then you should be able to keep running
the algorithm and obtain
the desired answer
i see thanks
and there is a question in the chat
how does it compare with the model with
online modification instead of erasures
um
yeah so i'm not
sure if the model of online
modifications has been defined in any
other work but we did consider it
and some of our results carry over also
to online modifications
you can show that
basically as long as the
oracle as long as the algorithm never
queries a point that has been erased by
the oracle so as long as this happens
with very small probability then the
tester can also work with online
modifications
so for example our linearity result
carries over to online modifications
but it definitely needs more
investigation
so uh
one more question
can you say anything about the error and
instead of erasures
um
[Music]
so is error also
something like online modifications
that's the same thing
honestly i also didn't yeah but if um
yeah it sounds like you're free to
elaborate then i will i will read that
it sounds like a similar question to
online modifications
yeah maybe so
yeah okay
um
any more questions
um
okay so um
one more time i invite the
speaker of uh
the first paper on the extension of
competitive
equilibrium with uh
chores
um to please share their slides
okay maybe we can um
move on to the next talk um
so uh you can um
please share your life and i i will let
you know when you have one minute left
sure
okay
thank you
so okay
so hi everyone i'm very happy to be here
to talk about my uh recent work
so let's start from a running example so
we have several restaurants
and we have two people alice and bob
they are reading these restaurants and
we want to give them proper rewards such
that they can provide
high quality ratings honest readings and
in such case we cannot use flat payments
because they will they can just provide
garbage but get our payments and also we
cannot check the answer because they are
just subjective answers there there's no
ground truth
and the third
traditional reverse system is like maybe
we can pay them according to their
agreements but in such case first even
they are honest they can have very
different tests and also if we only pay
them for the agreements
they can just give all the restaurant
the same score like the highest rating
and in such case there is no inform no
information but they can get all the
payments
so let me introduce one um
paradigm in my previous work with my
calculator so this uh is like we just
think their ratings for the restaurants
are ied samples
so we just think there are like infinite
number of restaurants so basically
infinite number of ied samples for some
joint random variables
and then we can just estimate the
contribution perfectly and this joint
distribution just represents for example
it's like for a random restaurant what
is the probability they both like it
what is the probability they both
dislike or one like when it's like
something like that and after we get the
joint distribution we can just like
calculate the mutual information based
on this transition intuitively in such
case like
no matter they are like positively
correlated or negatively correlated the
mutual information is high and we're
going to use this mutual information as
a payment
and the reason we want to use mutual
information is just because this data
processing quality
so at a high level it's just like if
someone if one of them like perform the
strategy
they're gonna like perform like
processor their ratings it will decrease
their payments and mathematically it's
just like they perform a strategy like
they're just multiplying some transition
matrix on the contribution
and the mutual information decrease and
we pay them by the merchant information
so their payment decrease in such case
they don't want to perform some strategy
on their ratings so that is what we want
we want them to provide their honest
original readings
okay
and i think you already noticed that the
problem here is like we just need
infinite number of like
restaurants they just need to read
infinite number because we want some
like perfect estimation of the
contribution and in practice they may
only read 10 restaurants we only assign
them 10 tasks in such case we only get
the frequency
metrics like how many restaurant labels
like something like that
and even we assume that they only care
about their expected payments in such
case we can just construct unbiased
meter but like
like the channel mutual information
there is like log there we cannot use
some finite number of samples to
construct so that
is my previous work so this is called
the determinant determinant-based mutual
information so this very simple it's
just defined as a determinant of the job
distribution matrix
and i put the absolute value there to
make sure it's non-negative and i can
also put square there it doesn't matter
and if satisfy data processing equality
i won't go into detail and the most
important thing here
is
it has this polynomial format so
determinant it has polynomial format in
such case we can have unbiased matter
with only a finite number of samples and
in like this 2x2 case we just only like
just like square we just only need four
restaurants four tasks there
and because of that we can just like use
this for
restaurants to construct the unbiased
method of this mutual information and
use this ambassador to pay them and
because it satisfied data processing
equality so it's fine
so the whole point here is that
we want a mutual information matter so
okay so this is the question this paper
wants to address
is any more
mutual information like that thus in
such case we can construct more reward
system have this property and this
actually this mutual information thing
reduces question to this information
matter design so we want the mutual
information to satisfy first data
processing and quality second issue has
polynomial format so this is true
property
and this is only in collector's slide
here i think also the only intellectual
idea in this paper
um
and maybe inappropriate a time you want
to use this it's like if clever is
something satisfied for shorter so if
i'm less clever than you and someone is
less clever than me and
like she or he also less clever you if
65 partial order and we want to create a
mountain function on this partial order
so basically we want to measure how
clever you are and we won't want this
matter to satisfy monotonicity
and one natural idea is that we can just
count the number of people that are less
clever than you right because if i'm
less clever than you
and then the people who less clever than
me gonna be less clever than you as well
and in such case the number of people
who are less clever than me
are going to be less than the number of
people who are less clever than you
maybe it's improper it's but it's just
idea here and that comes to this idea
this volume mutual information
so i'm going to measure how informative
this joint distribution is
by marrying the volume of the space of
the joint distribution that are less
informative than the original germ so i
see less informative it's just like this
data processing it like has some
transition part matrix multiplying left
and it's easy to prove is that by
partial order
and that is the idea this is the same
idea of this clever thing and the point
is
um if i define use this volume
i can't just use any measure like any
density as long as it's non-negative to
measure the volume and if if this
density is uniform density we can
actually get something proportional to
the determinant mutual information and
if this density is polynomial
and then it's polynomial so
so by definition
this this mutual information satisfy
data processing equality because data
processing quality essentially is a
mountain function regarding to the
partial order and i just defined this
way so it by definition satisfy data
process inequality and also by properly
choosing
the density function as polynomial we
can also make it as a polynomial and
remember what we need
is something satisfy data processing
quality and also has polynomial format
once we get this we can get unbiased
estimator
with finite number of samples which
means finite number of restaurants and
we can get the reward system we like
and
that's the whole point
and i think others are just like uh
this picture is just showing that what
is like how we tune this property of the
density and we can just get this new
mutual information
and i just meet there so the whole point
of this paper actually is just that new
mutual information family and satisfied
data processing party and being
polynomial
and because of that we can use
that to construct new family of reward
systems and satisfy this i i strategic
proof defined this way because of data
processing equality and also we only
need the participants to read
a finite number of tasks because we can
use that to construct unbiased method
and other properties uh you can't read
the paper for more details and i think
this oh
yeah
okay thank you very much thanks
any
question
for you king
okay so um
if there are any speaker from the paper
on the extension of competitive
equilibrium with chores um
please lots of snow now
[Music]
yeah i guess given the time constraints
and another session starting in room b
it's not practical if you haven't heard
from them
i guess there is a video
and uh eventually we'll hear back from
them okay yeah so there is a video in
the schedule and um
we can watch it all there
so thanks again
um
for the speakers who
get the talk in this this session and
also the attendance
um thank you very much and we'll see you
in the next session
thank you maya
thank you
thanks
you